Alhamdulillah.
for
[Silence]
real.
forch.
This narration here
deals with the transference of
knowledge.
Transferring knowledge from one person
to another. What are the parameters of
that? What kind of knowledge is
permissible
for us to spread amongst one another?
There are three things.
Number one,
that which is definitely from Allah.
Number two,
that which might be from Allah.
Number three, that which is definitely
not from Allah.
three levels.
So we have number one that which we know
for sure
Allah said or the messenger Muhammad
sallall.aii wasallam said this we are
commanded to spread
it is an obligation upon us. The second
is that which we know for sure is not
from Allah or his messenger.
That is categorically haram to spread.
Number three, that which possibly is
from Allah and his messenger. that which
might be from Allah and his messenger
and that is permissible
to articulate
without
certainty that it is from Allah or his
messenger. So we look at this narration
through that lens. The prophet
sallall.aii alaihi wasallam says exactly
spread and convey from me any meaning
anything that you know to come from me
even if only one verse
convey on my behalf even if only one
verse even if it's only one verse of the
Quran that you know convey it
he says and
it It is okay to tell the stories of
Benny is
the stories of the people of the book.
It is okay. He says, "And you can tell
those stories. There's no blame upon you
for doing so."
He says, "And whoever attributes
something to me that I have not said
purposely,
then let him take his place in the
fire."
So these are three levels. That which we
know to be from Allah,
convey on my behalf, even if only one
verse. that which we know not to be from
Allah and his messenger.
Then
so the first we know came from Allah we
are commanded to spread it. Second, that
which might be from Allah. We know the
people of the book Benu,
they were not very trustworthy over the
books that Allah entrusted them with.
They added,
they misconstrued,
they took away, they erased things, they
changed things for a multitude of
reasons. There's not one or two reasons.
There's many reasons
and this is why Allah sent a prophet
amongst them at all times.
He said
they were constantly overwatched by the
prophets themselves. Every time a
prophet would pass away, Allah would
raise up another amongst them as a
prophet. They couldn't be trusted with
their books. And even in the verses from
Bakar that we listen to tonight in
speaks about this that some groups, some
of their scholars would change and
meddle with the books and verses of
Allah. Why? For many reasons. Maybe he
wants to appease a king or a ruler.
Maybe he wants to gain a greater
following.
You know, when different companies
compete with each other, they sell the
same product. So, they're competing.
How do they get customers from one
another? Well, they play with the
prices, right? They play with the
prices, the quality.
The same thing would happen amongst
their scholars in those previous
nations. If a certain people were
disgruntled by something, he would
change a little thing here and then
people would come and follow him or they
would get paid to give certain fata
etc. Sometimes it's a unanimous change
that they make out of a out of
envy for
the rest of the nations.
something that Allah gave to
someone else, they wish that it was
theirs. what for instance? Does
anyone know an example of this?
our prophets. Okay, you're close.
So, they believe they're the gentile.
They're the they're the chosen ones,
right?
Their beliefs about being the chosen
people are so
are so
psychopathic
that they believe that they were buil
they were created from a special mud and
dirt and the rest of humanity was
created from a lower type of dirt. Those
are the Gentiles and we are the chosen.
But
Allah subhanahu wa tala rose two
children of Ibraim up. Correct? Is and
to each of those two nations Allah
distributed gifts.
One of those gifts was that is with his
father. He was the eldest and he was the
caretaker of the Ka and he was a
messenger to the Arabs, the Gentiles.
How could Isah be the one chosen to be
the offering and the slaughtered of his
children? No, it was his. We can't let
them have that. So they agree
that is
Isaiah was the one who was
who Ibraim was told to sacrifice and
not is
and the scholars of Islam agree that it
was is
he was a
what happened this has changed in those
books out of a a kind of pride for their
own lineage and their own.
And so it goes, many things were
changed, but not everything was changed.
Correct? not every single verse
from the Torah which we have today is
changed. Some of it is from Allah.
And some of the gospels that we have
today is from Allah. And some of the
psalms of David as zabul is from Allah.
And so when they tell us something from
their books,
is it from Allah or not from Allah?
Well, there's three types. There's that
which we know for sure is from Allah. We
don't need their books to tell us that.
We already have it in ours.
The second is that which we know
categorically is not from Allah
the trinity and any verses
misconstrued that articulate that anyone
is the son or daughter of Allah that
which we know to be categorically a lie.
It is haram to narrate these things from
them. Then there's that which we're not
sure. It could be from Allah but it
might not be. This is usually stories,
anecdotes,
right? Something happened, someone went
out. The prophet sallallah.aii wasallam
told us many stories this. And when
they moved to Medina in the time of the
prophet sallallah.aii wasallam, there
were three Jewish tribes there.
Wabanua
these three Jewish tribes would
intermingle with the Arabs and tell
them stories from their books. So the
prophet sallallah.aii wasallam
instructed the companions and Bkari
listen to what his instructions are. He
said
He said, "If
if the people of the book, the Jews of
Medina or anyone else, if they relate to
you a story from their books, do not
reject it as falsehood and do not accept
it as truth. We're uncertain of it. We
don't know. Is it possible?" Yes. Is it
definite? No. And this is usually like
we said anecdotes
things that you know a man something
happened to a particular man and this
occurred Allah said and
he said and this happened this is
something that is possible.
So
if it is something that is possible it's
permissible for us to hear it. It's
permissible for us to tell it to each
other if there is some need for that.
But does that mean that just because he
says
that we should use their books as a
an explanation of the Quran?
Huh? Of course not. Absolutely not. And
this is one of the mistakes that is
considered to be something that many
of the imams and scholars of the
Muslim have rejected throughout the
years and that is a tap that is written
and it is filled with with stories of
beni is to fill in some of the details
of the stories mentioned in the Quran.
This is something that is highly
discouraged.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala gave us
details in the Quran that we needed and
he left out whatever we don't need.
Knowing those details is
inconsequential.
How many people were with
when he was on the on the ark? How many
people Allah?
If I told you it was 40 people, would
that change anything? What about if I
told you it was 43 people?
Does that change anything for you? What
about Misam,
his staff that would turn into a snake?
What if I told you it was made
out of it was made out of cherry,
cherrywood?
Does that change anything for us? What
if I told you it was made of walnut?
What if I told you it was made of oak?
Who cares? What about the number of the
young men that went into the cave in
surah?
If I told you they were seven and their
dog was their eighth or if I told you
they were 700 and their dog was their
701st, would it change anything for us
practically? Absolutely not. And so
Allah
scrubbed those details from the stories
that he tells us in the Quran and gave
us exactly what we need. Not a drop more
and not a drop less. But the people of
the book, they were obsessed with this
type of knowledge. They were obsessed
with it. Musam tells them, "Slaughter a
cow."
He said, "A cow? Huh? What kind of cow?
A cow.
Well, how old is this cow?
It is medium. It's not too old. It's not
too young.
What color is this cow? What does this
cow do for a living?
Is it a cow that's used to till? Is it a
cow that's used to
All you're doing is making things more
difficult on yourself. If if you had a
son or a daughter, you said, "Go get me
a glass of water." They turn to you and
they say, "A tall glass or a short
glass, a big glass or a small glass, a
fancy one or a regular one? Do you want
this glass made out of glass or is glass
metaphorical and you mean plastic? Would
you this water to be lukewarm or
slightly cold or slight? What do you
understand from this exchange? You
understand that they don't want to go
get it? They're stalling. They're trying
to make you give up on them. And this is
what the people of the book before us
did. And all of that extra knowledge
that they have is not actually
knowledge. It's just details that only
serve to bog down and take away from the
take away from the ethos of the great
and the grandeur and the gravity of
these stories that Allah tells us in the
Quran and Sunnah. So this
this is the type of knowledge that it is
permissible for us to articulate to each
other. It's not obligatory. It's not
necessarily even encouraged. It's
permissible. Now when the prophet tells
us
it's permissible to narrate from beni
does that mean we should go out and buy
a bible or go out and buy the old
testament or the new testament and then
read it in detail is that and then use
this narration as an evidence to do that
absolutely not there's a difference
between being approached with something
something that you hear incidentally and
actively going to seek knowledge
with these types of people or from these
books. That is a very different kettle
of fish. The last thing he tells us is
whoever
ascribes to me that which I have not
said purposely then let him assume his
place in the hellfire.
And then comes along WhatsApp and
Facebook,
right? The Muslim were so safe for so
long. And then you'll wake up and you'll
find narrations coming to you from all
over. And then it's Ali's job to now
research and look for these narrations.
Right? So for instance
when the moon landing occurred, the moon
landing it turned into
there was a narration floating around.
The day of judgment will not commence
until two men walk around on the moon.
Ya Allah. And then they say, "Is this
authentic or inauthentic? Could you look
for this narration for us?"
Right?
It is haram
to spread a narration without knowing
that the scholars of Islam have approved
and authenticated this narration.
I will repeat what I said. It is haram
to spread a narration
ascribed to the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam without knowing for certain
that at least one major scholar of Islam
has authenticated this narration.
So for instance a narration from Sah
Bkari do we know that that's authentic
or not? Yes.
Muslim. Yes.
No,
that's not a book that was written for
the general masses. It has in it about a
fourth of its narrations are authentic
and the rest is all kinds of stuff.
And so it goes. A person before they say
they need the authority to do that. What
is the authority? A major scholar of
Islam has authenticated this narration.
They have said this is authentic.
Who are major scholars? Albkari, Muslim,
Abu Dani,
, Ibuza, Iban,
, Abdi,
Abu Hati,
Ahmed, Ibn Helb
of the later scholars and
right these are major scholars Ib etc
etc. If we have a narration that we got
from them and they said this narration
is authentic then spread it otherwise
you are just being part of the problem.
[Arabic recitation]